>> WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
IT WAS A
Spitting out of control.
Beyond even my predictions.
Calls for IMPEACHMENT.
VULGARITY RAIDS.
PLANS FOR A BEING 00% TAX HIKE.
A BILL TO RADICAL ALTER THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S ONLY DAY 2 OF THE DEMIC
CONTROLLED, HATE TRUMP, HOWLS OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
THE WHEELS ARE COMING OFF.
IT'S NOT A PRETTY PICTURE.
AS YOU WATCH TONIGHT, BE SURE TO
ASK YOURSELF THIS IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
WE'LL BE ASKING QUESTIONS THEY
NEVER ASK IN THE MEDIA.
IS WHAT YOU ARE HEARING AND
SEEING AND WITNESSING, IS IT
GOOD FOR YOU, FOR YOUR FAMILY?
IS IT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY THAT
WE LIVE.
WE START TODAY WITH OUR
CONGRESSIONAL WATCH.
I'VE LONG WARNED YOU IN A
HUNDRED DAYS, THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
WILL KNOW WHAT WE KNOW AND THAT
IS, JUST HOW RADICAL THIS NEW
CONGRESS IS.
AND WE'RE GETTING OFF TO A QUICK
START WANT JUST HOURS LAST NIGHT
AFTER GETTING SWORN IN, RASHEEDA
TALIB.
WENT ON A PROFANITY RANT.
THEY FILED THAT, YESTERDAY, TOO.
THEY'RE IN A RUSH.
FOR WHAT REASON, GOD ONLY KNOWS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PEOPLE LOVE YOU AND YOU WIN.
MAMMA, LOVES YOU.
I SAID, BABY, THEY DON'T.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO GO IN
THERE AND IMPEACH THE [BLEEP].
DON'T SAY T. WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT BUT DON'T SAY IT.
IS THIS WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS BECOME ISN'T MEDIA?
THEY HATE TRUMP EVERY SECOND OF
EVERY HOUR AND DAY. THIS
CONGRESSWOMAN DOUBLED DOWN,
TWEETING QUOTE, I WILL ALWAYS
SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER.
HASHTAG.
UNAPOLOGETICALLY.
BUT TODAY, SHE WAS A LITTLE TO
AFRAID TO ANSWER REPORTER'S
QUESTIONS, INCLUDING SERIOUS XM
PATRIOTS Z. ASKED HER DIRECTLY
AND L SHE DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO
GIVE AN ANSWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE]
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOUR CALL FOR
IMPEACHMENT?
>> BY THE WAY, SO MUCH ABOUT
SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER.
AND PICKET ALSO GOT EXCLUSIVE
FOOTAGE OF TLEB'S DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES, DEFENDING VULGARITY
RAID, SUPPORTING THE PRESIDENT'S
IMPEACHMENT.
I WARNED YOU, THEY NEVER EVER
ARE GOING TO TELL WHAT THE REAL
AGENDA S. THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT WENT OUT M CAMPAIGNED
AND HELPED A LOT OF SENATORS.
KEPT THE SENATE REPUBLICANS AT
HAND, WAS A HUGE WIN FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
HE DIDN'T LOSE 60 SEATS LIKE
CLINTON.
OBAMA LOST 63.
HOUSE SEATS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE SHALL SEAT RESULTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE LEADER OF THE DEMOCRATS, I'M
NOT IN THE CENSORSHIP BUSINESS.
I DON'T THINK THAT I MORNING I
DON'T LIKE THAT LANGUAGE.
I WOULDN'T USE THAT LANGUAGE.
I DON'T AGAIN.
ESTABLISH ANY LANGUAGE STANDARD
FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
WORSE THAN THE PRESIDENT, WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID.
SOME OF THE WORDS ME USES, HAS A
DIRECT IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S LIVES.
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS DO NOT
HAVE AN AFFECT ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
>> REMEMBER I TOLD ON YOU
WEDNESDAY, UNLIKE THE HATE TRUMP
MEDIA, WE'RE GOING TO HOLD ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
NOW, REMEMBER, YESTERDAY, NANCY
PELOSI MADE THIS MENEKO.
>> HE'S NEVER GOING TO BE
CONVICT IN THE U.S. SENATE, NO
MATTER HOW MUCH THE PHONY NEWS
MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY, THE HATE
TRUMP MEDIA SAYS IT'S GOING TO
H. IT'S NOT.  AND DEMOCRATS ARE
FIND BEING PLENTY OF TIME FOR
OTHER STUPID FOLLIES THAT WILL
NEVER PASS.
NOW, FAR LEFT TRUMP HATER,
CONGRESSMAN, STEVEN COHEN HAS
ALREADY INTRODUCED TWO
CONSTITUTION AT AMENDMENTS.
THEY WILL ANY NOWHERE.
HE'S WASTING YOUR TIME.
THIS IS FALSE HOPE.
THE MEDIA WILL HYPE IT UP AND IT
WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
ONE THAT WILL ELIMINATE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND ONE FROM
PARRED THE PRESIDENT PARDONING
HIM.
THEY ALSO WANT THEIR CRUMBS
BACK.
CORTEZ, IS NOW CALLING, GET
THIS, SHE WANTS A 70% FEDERAL
TAX RATE FOR THE RICH.
70%.
NOW, IF YOU LIVE IN NEW YORK.
YOU HAVE A 10% STATE INCOME TAX.
THAT'S 80.
IN NEW YORK CITY, THAT'S ANOTHER
4%.
WESTCHESTER COUNTY, THE TWO
HIGHEST PROPERTY TAX COUNTIES IN
THE CLERK THAT'S 90 CENTS OF
EVERY DOLLAR SHE WANTS PEOPLE TO
PAVEMENT BUT SHE'S SAYING
ONLY 70-CENTS OR 70% NATIONALLY,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU LOOK AT OUR TAX RATES
BACK IN THE 60'S Q. YOU HAVE A
PROGRESS TAX RATE SYSTEM, YOUR
TAX RATE, YOU KNOW, LET'S SAY
FROM ZERO TO $75,000 MAY BE 10%
OR 15%, ET CETERA.
BUT ONCE YOU GET TO LIKE, THE
TIPPY TOP
SHE THINKS SHE'S FDR AND ABRAHAM
LINCOLN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THAT IT ONLY HAS EVER
BEEN RADICAL FOR THE CHANGE THIS
COUNTRY.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN MADE A RADICAL
DECISION TEOSINTE EMANCIPATION
PROCLOMATION.
>> THE CONGRESSWOMAN, YOU'RE
WELCOME ON THIS PROGRAM.
I'D LOVE TO SPEND AN HOUR,
TALKING ABOUT YOUR GREAT
SOCIALIST IDEAS.
OTHER DEMOCRATS, THEY'RE
PLOTTING OTHER RADICAL SOCIALIST
ECONOMIC CHANGES AND IN OUR
HANNITY WATCH ON THE ECONOMY
FEATURE TONIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FREE MARKET.
LOW REGULATION, LOW TAX POLICIES
THEY WERE WORKING IN REALTIME
FOR REAL AMERICAN IN THE MONTH
OF DECEMBER.
LOOK AT THIS.
JOB NUMBERS FAR EXCEEDED ALL
EXPECTATIONS, AS THE U.S.
ECONOMY FOR DECEMBER, ADDEDDED A
CHOPPING 312,000 NEW JOBS, AND
FOR THE FIRST TIME BY THE WAY,
FROM 20 YEARS, WE NOW HAVE REAL
WAGE INCREASE OF OVER 3% FOR THE
AMERICAN WORKER.
2018 ENDED WITH A RECORD NUMBER
OF AMERICAN IN THE WORKFORCE O.
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY, POSTED
THEIR BIGGEST JOB GAINS  IN 20
YEARS.
HIS UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT ITS
LOWEST POINT EVER.
ADD TO THAT AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
OUR VETS ARE GETTING JOBS IN THE
LARGEST NUMBERS WE HAVE SEEN IN
A LONG TIME AND WE ARE NOW THE
LARGEST PRODUCER OF CRUDE OIL IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
THAT'S RIGHT.
MORE THAN RUSSIA. AND MORE THAN
SAUDI ARABIA.
THE LIFE BLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY.
PRICE OF GASOLINE HAS DROPPED
CONSIDERABLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING
HISTORY.
EVERY DAY, THE MEDIA THAT HATES
HIM, WILL NEVER TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE HE'S KEEPING HIS
PROMISES.
OUR ECONOMY RIGHT NOW IS RUNNING
ON ALL CYLINDERS AND YOU WOULD
PROBABLY KNOW IT IF YOU WATCHED
FAKE NEWS CNN OR CONSPIRACY TV,
MSNBC IN FACT, MOST MEMBERS OF
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAVE THE
EXACT SAME M.O. AS THEIR FRIENDS
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT HATING TRUMP.
EVERY SECOND, EVERY HOUR, EVERY
DAY, NOTHING CHANGES.
NOTHING ELSE SEEMS TO MATTER.
FOR EXAMPLE, LOOK AT THIS CNN
FAKE NEWS COMMENTATOR AND WHAT
DID SHE TO SAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT, HE'S A WHINER.
HE WHINES LIKE A BABY.
HE'S A LIAR AND A WIENER, THE
REPUBLICANS GOT TO GO OVER THERE
AND CHANGE THE PRESIDENT'S
DIAPERS, DON, THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS COMING DOWN TO SO HE CAN CUT
IT OUT SO THE GROWN FOLKS, THE
BIG GIRLS AND THE BIG BOYS CAN
SIT AROUND THE TABLE AND DO WHAT
IS NEGATIVES FOR THIS
GOVERNMENT.
>> JUST IMAGINE FOR A SECOND, A
CONSERVATIVE THAT SAID THAT
DURING THE OBAMA YEARS.
NOW, IN THE VERY SAME SHOW, A
PUNDIT ATTACKED TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
OF COURSE, CLINGING TO OUR GOD,
GUNS AND RELIGION, THEN WE WERE
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, SMELLY
WAL-MART PEOPLE AND NOW, WE'RE
ALL TOOTHLESS BECAUSE WE LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
THOSE OF US THAT VOTE FOR HIM.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE WALL IS ALWAYS BEEN A
CONFOR DONALD TRUMP ACRED LOWS
BASE.
THE WALL HAS ALWAYS BEEN A SCAM.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A LIE.
NOTHING ABOUT THE WALL HAS EVER
BEEN REAL AND DONALD TRUMP KNOWS
T.
>> ACTUALLY, WE'VE BEEN BUILDING
THE WALL, BUT WHY LET TRUTH AND
FACTS GET IN THE WAY OF A GOOD
NARRATIVE TO HATE TRUMP AND SNOT
TO BE OUT DONE, ON
LIBERAL "MORNING JOE" ONCE
AGAIN, PLAYING THE RACE CARD.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR TWO
YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LOOK, THIS IS ALL DONALD HAS
LEFT.
HE IS WANTING THIS WALL IS NOT A
WALL.
IT IS A LET'S AMERICA WHITE
AGAIN AND BASIC AFTER THE
ACCIDENT HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
ECONOMY ANYMORE.
THIS IS ALL HE HAS LEFT.
THAT ONE METAPHOR.
THAT ONE THING THAT TALKS THAT
39%, 40%, 41%.
NEITHER THE BLACK MAN, BROWN
MAN, JEWISH MAN, MEDIA MAN, BANK
MAN.
YOU'RE NOT IN A POSITION FOR
YOU.
>> WHAT DID I TELL YOU
WEDNESDAY.
WE'RE IN THE WORST INFORMATIONAL
CRISIS THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER
FACED, IN TERMS OF THEIR
FIXATION ON HAITI AND THE
PRESIDENT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
HISTORICALLY STRONG ECONOMY,
STRONG NEW TRADE DEALS, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, A MORE PEACEFUL
AND PROS PROUS WORLD, BUT THE
LEFT IS OBSESSED WITH ONE THING
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
FEED YOU, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY
DAY.
THAT'S WHY THIS SHOW IS
DIFFERENT.
WE LIKE TO LOOK AT OURSELVES AS
A LITTLE BIT OF AN ISLAND OR
OASIS, THAT BRINGS US TO HANNITY
WATCH ON BOARD SECURITY TONIGHT
AND AN UPDATE ON THE PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AT THIS
HOUR.
FACING GRIDLOCK IN WASHINGTON
ALL BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
FIGHTING TOOTH AND NAIL AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT'S VOW TO SECURE
ARMED BORDERS WITH WALL AND
FENCING.
A WALL THAT BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ARE ASKING FOR.
A WALL THAT PROTECTS OUR
HOMELAND, A WALL THAT KEEPS OUT
GANG MEMBERS  AND POTENTIAL
TERRORISTS.
THEY HAVE A BIG DERIVATIVE DOOR
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE A PART
OF OUR FAMILY.
AND TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
EFFECTIVELY ADVOCATED ON THIS
VERY PERSONALITY ISSUE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS
STRETCH.
THEY BRING CHILDREN OR EVEN
WORSE, THEY USE CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW, CHILDREN ARE THE
BIGGEST BENEFICIARIES OF WHAT WE
WANT TO DO.
CHILDREN ARE HURT MORE THAN
ANYBODY ELSE.
THESE COYOTES WHAT, THEY DO WITH
CHILDREN, ALL BECAUSE WE HAVE
OPEN BORDERS BECAUSE THEY THINK
THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH T. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAPPENS THERE IS
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
MAYBE THAT'S THE WORST OF ALL.
WHERE YOU HAVE TRAFFICKERS,
HAVING THREE AND FOUR WOMEN WITH
TAPE ON THEIR MOUTHS AND TIED
UP.
SO THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE GOING TO
STOP THAT IS BY HAVING A SOLID
STEAL STRUCTURE OR CONCRETE
STRUCTURE.
>> NOW, THE PRESIDENT ISSUE
TODAY STERN WARNING, TELLING
REPORTERS HE IS WILLING TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY IN
ORDER TO GET THAT WALL BUILT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
>> HAVE YOU CONSIDERED USING
EMERGENCY POWERS TO GRANT
YOURSELF AUTHORITY TO BUILD THIS
WALL, WITHOUT CONGRESSIONAL
APPROVAL?
AND.
>> YES.
I HAVE.
>> YOU HAVE?
>> YES.
I V. I CAN DO IT IF I WANT.
>> YOU DON'T NEED CONGRESSIONAL
APPROVAL.
>> ABSOLUTE LEAST WE CAN CALL A
NATIONAL MORE THAN BECAUSE OF
THE SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
ABSOLUTELY.
I HAVEN'T DONE IT.
I MAY DO IT. BUT WE CAN CALL A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND BUILD IT
VERY QUICKLY AND IT'S ANOTHER
WAY OF DOING IT.
BUT IF WE CAN DO IT THROUGH A
NEGOTIATED PROCESS, WE'RE GIVING
THAT A SHOT.
>> NOW, ONE MESSAGE TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TONIGHT IS THIS
IS IMPORTANT.
LIVES ARE AT STAKE.
WE DON'T WANT DRUGS FLOODING
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HEADS GOT TO
STOP.
WE CAN'T HAVE A POTENTIAL WHERE
TERRORIST CONSIST WALK ACROSS
OUR BORDERS OR GANG MEMBERS THAT
WANT TO COMMIT VIOLENCE OR THE
DRUG CARTELS, HAVING ACCESS TO
OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE GOT TO PROTECT OUR
BORDERS.
IT IS ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY.
EVEN IF THE 99% OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO COME IN, JUST WANT A
BETTER LIFE.
YOU REPUBLICANS HAVE TO STATE
COURSE.
YOU CAN'T BACK DOWN.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT'S BASE IS NOW
DEEPLY INVESTED IN THIS
SHUTDOWN, THE PRESIDENT HAS
TAKEN A STAND AND IT'S TIME FOR
THE REPUBLICANS TO DO THE SAME.
HOW MANY MORE INNOCENT
AMERICANS, THINK ABOUT THIS,
WOULD NEED TO DIE BEFORE
DEMOCRATS -- FIVE YEARS AGO,
SUPPORTED BUILDING A WALL --
WILL PROTECT THE BORDER?
I'M NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
MURDER.
THE IPHONE, IPAD I DIDN'T CRISIS
IN SMALL TOWNS AND BIG CITIES.
MOST OF THOSE DRUGS, ESPECIALLY
THE HEROIN, ARE COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY FROM THE CARTELS.
THEY ARE TARGETING OUR KIDS.
THE UNITED STATES LITERALLY HAS
ARRESTED THOUSANDS EVER PEOPLE
WITH TIES TO TERROR
ORGANIZATIONS.
GANG MEMBERS, VIOLENT CARTELS,
TRYING TO CROSS OUR BORDERS,
ALONG WITH PEOPLE THAT JUST WANT
A BETTER LIFE.
WE CAN HAVE IT.
WE CAN HAVE LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WATCH THIS.
>> STOPPED OVER SPECIAL INTEREST
ALIENS.
THOSE ARE ALIENS, THE INTEL
COMMUNITY HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT
ARE OF CONCERN.
THEY HAVE PATTERNS IDENTIFIED
WITH SERIOUS TRAVEL PATTERNS OR
THEY HAVE KNOWN OR SUSPECTED
TIES TO TERRORISM.
SO WE HAVE 3,000 THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT.
I THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT
CONTINUES TO MAKE CLEAR IS IT'S
OUR SOVEREIGN DUTY TO KNOW WHO
COMES INTO OUR COUNTRY, WITHOUT
ANY KIND OF A STRUCTURE, WITHOUT
CHANGING THE LAWS, THEY HAVE NO
WAY TO KNOW THE IDENTITY OF
EVERY PERSON THAT WALKS ACROSS
THE UNSECURED BORDER.
>> THAT'S SECRETARY NEILSON IS
RIGHT.
IT SHOULD SCARE EVERY AMERICAN.
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
AND BORDER SECURITY, IT'S ALSO
ABOUT SAVING AMERICAN JOBS AT
FAIR WAGES.
NOW, THE MAN WHO WROTE THE DEAL,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS STANDING BY, READY TO
NEGOTIATE ALL THROUGHOUT
CHRISTMAS AND NEW YEAR'S
HOLIDAY.
HE WANT ACE SOLUTION, AS IT
RELATES TO DAWKA, HE'S PUT THAT
ON THE -- DACA, HE'S PUT THAT ON
THE TABLE.
SOMETHING THE DEMOCRATS WANT,
HE'S WILLING TO TALK ABOUT THE
DREAMERS AS WELL.
WATCH THIS.
>> SENATOR SCHUMER CAME OUT AND
SAID THE MEETING FROM HIS POINT
OF VIEW AND SPEAKER PELOSI WAS
CONTENTIOUS.
THIS IS HIM QUOTING YOU.
THAT THE SHUTDOWN COULD GO ON
FOR MONTHS, OR A YEAR OR LONGER.
DID YOU SAY THAT.
>> I DID.
I DID.
ABSOLUTELY, I SAID THAT.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL.
BUT I AM PREPARED AND I THINK I
CAN SPEAK FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE
LOWS AND REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE.
THEY FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
HAVING A SAFE COUNTRY, HAVING A
BORDER THAT MAKES SENSE, WITHOUT
BORDERS, I'VE SAID IT MANY
TIMES.
WE DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T GO ON EVEN
BEYOND A FEW MORE DAYS.
IT REALLY COULD OPEN VERY
QUICKLY.
>> WE PLAYED THE TAPE.
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTED THIS FIVE
YEARS AGO.
HILLARY SUPPORTED IT, SCHUMER
SUPPORTED IT.
BARACK OBAMA SUPPORTED T.
APPARENTLY, NANCY PELOSI DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT SAFETY AND SECURITY
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
APPARENTLY, NOT CARING ABOUT
DACA RECIPIENTS THAT THEY TALK
SO MUCH ABOUT.
NOT CARING ABOUT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS, THEY WERE PELTED WITH
ROCKS  AND BOTTLES.
SHE JUST CARES ABOUT SCORING
CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS, WHICH IS
WHY ARROGANTLY, SHE OFFERED
PRESIDENT TRUMP ONE DOLLARS FOR
THE WALL.
, I GUESS SHE WAS FEELING GIDDY
YESTERDAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> UNDER WHAT SITUATION WOULD
YOU ACCEPT A DOLLAR OF WALL
FUNDING FOR THIS PRESIDENT, IN
ORDER TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT?
>> A DOLLAR?
A DOLLAR.
$1.
YES.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE FROM TONIGHT'S
RADICAL WATCH, THE RADICAL BASE
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY
ARE ALREADY ON HIM.
I THINK TELL TAKE A HUNDRED DICE
FULLY UNDERSTAND IT.
WE'RE UNDERSTANDING IT NOW ON
DAY 2.
MANY ON THE LEFT, INCLUDING
NEARLY EVERYONE ON EVERY OTHER
NETWORK BECAUSE OF COURSE, IT'S
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA.
THEY SEEM TO WANT A WEAKER
COUNTRY, FILLED WITH LOFTY,
SURREAL, PROGRESSIVE PRINCIPLES
AND THEY'RE NOT LOOKING OUT FOR
THE SAFETY OF YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY, BUT PROGRESSIVE
PRINCIPLES COME WITH SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES.
NOT ONLY WILL WE HAVE SECURITY
BORDERS, HIGHER TAXES.
AT LEAST ECONOMIC GROWTH THAT IS
STAGNANT.
OPEN BORDERS.
THAT CAN LEAD TO DEATH AND
TERROR AND DRUGS.
IF PROGRESSIVES TAKE OVER, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WILL
DRASTICALLY BE IN DECLINE.
IS THAT THE AMERICA YOU.
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS WE HAVE
TO ASK.
SO MY HUMBLE ADVICE IS THE
SHUTDOWN, AS MUCH OF AN
INCONVENIENCE, SOME PEOPLE THAT
WORK FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND I
HOPE THEY GET THEIR BACK PAY, IT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE, STRAIGHT
THROUGHOUT STATE OF THE UNION
AND MAYBE BEYOND.
THE STATE OF THE UNION, THE
PRESIDENT, HE CAN TAKE HIS CASE
DIRECTLY TO YOU, WE, THE PEOPLE.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
SUPPORT BACK PAY FOR THOSE
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES, MAKE NO
MISTAKE.
NO MATTER WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DOES, HE MUST HOLD FIRM ON THIS
BORDER WALL FUNDING FROM
CONGRESS.
THERE MUST BE NOAM NESTY UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
LINDSAY GRAM, HE HAS MADE A
PROPOSED COMPROMISE THAT WOULD
GIVE DACA RECIPIENTS, THREE
YEARS OF A WORK PERMIT THAT THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO RENEW DOWN THE
LINE.
IF THERE'S NOAM NESTY, AND MONEY
TO PROTECT THE WALL FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY WILL HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED SOMETHING VERY
PERSONALITY.  AND THEY'LL
POLITICALLY BENEFIT FROM T. IF
THEY CAPITULATE REPUBLICANS, THE
POLITICAL DAMAGE, FRANKLY IS
INCALCULABLE, AND IT WILL HOUND
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW,
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.